early morning in Medway jubilation
[Applause]
sign of things to calm labor take in
this Kent Council for the first time
this historic win just the start and
this man overjoyed
today promising a new chapter make no
mistake we are on course for a labor
majority at the next general election
that's his hope and progress across
swathes of Southern England crucial to
hitting it
Swindon another to switch
key marginal territory taken sending a
message to the conservatives change
could be coming
unfortunately National issues just seem
to have overwhelmed the whole situation
and hence we've got the results we've
got a brave face for the PM arriving at
party headquarters armed with sandwiches
for staffers but this very bad and he
knows it it's always disappointing to
this hard-working conservative
councilors their friends their
colleagues and I'm so grateful to them
for everything that they've done but as
the day progressed and Counting
continued the results for the
conservatives fell further
Dover in Kent wants a true brexit
Battleground now moving behind labor
these are local elections but these are
a fantastic set of results for us the
spread of our victories overnight and
into today shows actually that we are
making gains in the areas that we need
to be winning for that next general
election
into the West Midlands and pockets of
the north of England father starmus
success Stoke on Trent reclaimed a brick
back in the red wall
but a long way to go the conservatives
still with a foothold in Boris Johnson
brexit land holding ground in Warsaw
Dudley and Stockton too
for both sides winning here crucial to
deliver a general election victory
[Music]
but any Prospect of that for the
conservatives today dashed nationally we
haven't been helped I think there's been
difficulties and I think the party needs
to reflect on some of the losses that
we've had
bath Devon to decorum Surrey to
Stratford on Avon safe Southern
Heartland smashed liberal Democrat
leader Ed Davies celebrating in Windsor
and maidenhead a once true blue Borough
three two one
now calling time on Tory rule I've been
saying for a long time now the liberal
Democrats are the challenges to the
conservatives across the blue wall seats
in the south of England and Nazi in a
few other places too millions of votes
counted the results are in and these
local elections suggests that
sarcastarma is on course to become the
next prime minister it's an incredible
achievement for the labor leader but he
still has a mountain to climb if he
wants to win an outright majority
because these results suggest that we're
heading for a hung Parliament with labor
the largest party
are you facing a Wipeout prime minister
the results speak for themselves this a
disaster do you reckon you'll be able to
turn this around but the Prime Minister
finding comfort in greeting foreign
leaders at number 10. the coronation and
welcome distraction from his domestic
woes but nothing to celebrate for him
here Beth Rigby Sky News in Westminster